I am exhausted.
I just uh got myself in a very hard 5k
and a bunch of lifting and I'm tapped
for the week.
can't be tapped for the week. I got to
stream all day tomorrow. Got to work on
some stuff. So, here's what we're going
to do today. Um, I'm not going to try to
mess with anything super fancy. I'm just
going to play around with our sweeps.
I'm going to see if I can figure out a
couple quirks that uh we have with them
and uh we're going to go from there.
We're going to see what happens. Yeah.
So, there's no point in us keeping on
this run because it's not sweeping uh
everything the way that we want it to
anyways.
It is doing decently though.
And what I'm specifically hoping is that
this run here
gives us uh some quite usable
parameters.
Believe it should.
I believe that it should. So yeah, this
is not sweeping the network at all. Uh
it should be sweeping the net params. So
I would believe that this is about as
good as we can do without touching the
net params.
Oh,
wait. Huh?
I don't understand this. Why?
Wait,
why are parameters not here?
huh?
Yeah, this looks very very bad.
So apparently I just ran like several
hundred experiments without sweeping
anything.
I don't know how that would be possible.
That's a sweep.
What on earth did I do?
I mean that's quite a red. Then I guess
we just have like unstable hypers cuz we
had some runs get to 5k
score on this
h
at least this is a good uh a good reason
for it to have not like done
ridiculously well. So let's see.
arcs.
Right.
I think I know what happened.
You imbecile.
You utter imbecile. Okay.
Well, that was completely dumb.
Well, I want to check that this is
correct now.
Um, unfortunately, I don't want to like
do a full sweep.
That was a really dumb error. That's a
really dumb way to lose some experiment
data.
It's kind of crazy though that there was
that much variance in um
like look how much variance there was,
right?
So this one here is like close to 5k
score. So if these are all the same
hypers, right? And this is actually
filtered. If I take this off and I just
like
Yeah. 50 runs.
It's quite a bit of variance, right?
Like some of these are only down at 2K.
Some of them are all the way up at 4.8.
Oh, and look, we have we have the
distribution right here.
Ignore these ones. These are probably
manual runs.
Okay, it's not that bad though. Like
they're not just failing.
Yeah. So, we can see here now that this
is actually sweeping correctly because
it's exploring different size networks
and such.
I do actually kind of wonder though
because
I do wonder if there's going to be this
thing where like smaller nets train
quicker.
We probably have to mess with that.
There's honestly probably like a lot
that we need to still do on this sweep
space
because now we're sweeping net
architecture basically as well. So this
is no longer just hypers.
But we've done enough innovation for one
update, I'd say.
Well, that's a little disheartening.
Um, what are we going to do now? Cuz
that they're kind of go my plans for the
afternoon.
See if we have a reply here. And then we
will uh we'll come up with something to
do.
I guess one thing we should do, let's
sort of quantify.
We'll let this do a few experiments in
the meantime.
Quantifying
complexity.
How much jank is there
sweeps?
I think there are only like a couple
hundred lines realistically.
silly
puff around.
I just want to quantify like how much
crap I think there is still in uh each
of these. So what we have 1300 lines
here. Let's just kind of look at the
code.
Train is fast.
We're short
dashboard.
Q puff advantage binding.
is fine.
Profiling utilization
I'm just kind of going through and
trying to figure out like how much
better do I think I can make everything
by I mean like how much shorter can I
make everything
Okay, they're like some small chunks of
reused logic, I suppose.
It's actually not that bad, though. I
would say
It's not actually as bad as I think.
It's like not super redundant. It's
mostly just messy.
1,800 lines of modules garbage.
Okay, let's figure this out. So, log
co-ops and values. This doesn't get
used,
right?
Yeah, I don't think this gets used.
use PO laws. Plus massive.
Holy crap.
Oh, yeah. This is the optimized one.
Okay. So, I think like twothirds of this
file just gets deleted.
We can even do that today. That's super
easy.
And then some of these functions that
live here are a little questionable.
Uh, the nice thing is a lot of this is
hand editable.
Life without Tik Tok instead of been so
good. Thanks. I'm telling you, man. It's
poison.
I think the thing that I'm guilty of
most is uh when I get like playing a
game, I'll go watch a whole bunch of
YouTube about the game. At the very
least though, it's long form content.
It's not short form,
which feels substantially better, but it
would still be way better if um you
know, in between doing other stuff, I
just listen to my audio book instead of
watching garbage.
I think audiobooks are basically the
only form of entertainment where I can
just like enjoy it, relax, and then not
keep thinking about it in the background
throughout the rest of my day.
Feel like I could actually focus. Yeah,
I It's the most ADHD inducing stuff
ever.
Like manufactured ADHD. It's awful.
Like this stuff should just not exist.
Able to set up the phone.
No,
I was lazy.
There's some cool stuff done though.
I'm kind of just going through right
now. Um I'm going through all the code
that I have and just like assessing
redundancy, right? I'm just like
figuring out here because like if I do
this
Right? Like we have
300 lines here, 1,000 lines, 1,800
lines,
4,400 lines of C++,
not including our tests files.
So, what of this do we actually need,
etc., etc.
How's your sleep? Like sucked last night
because I stayed up late being stupid
and then the dog woke me up this
morning. Um,
but you should aim to get like eight
plus hours, ideally more.
Like if you're if you're also keeping in
good shape and you're not blessed with
amazing genetics, you can very easily
need more than eight hours.
Sleep is very important. As someone who
spent like many of my formative years
not sleeping at all, sleep deprivation
is pretty much indistinguishable from
depression. It feels awful.
Like do not compromise your sleep.
Yeah, don't stay up watching that. If
you need something to fall asleep, uh, I
highly recommend an Audible
subscription.
You don't have to be looking at your
phone. You can just listen to a book
until you get tired and then just turn
it off and go to sleep immediately. It's
great.
That's actually the one thing that when
I do that consistently, it has it's
noticeably better the next day.
When I revise most context,
mostly context, I forget
stuff the next day.
Is it my
man? I honestly
I I don't know if you're in undergrad or
if you're in high school or grad school
or what. Um, in my younger years it was
awful. I basically was so constantly
exhausted and sleepd deprived that I
would have to study for three times as
long to retain anything and then it
would just be a vicious slight cycle
where I'd be working over a 100 hours a
week and not sleeping
and trying to also have to play sports.
Um, you retain information better fresh
well rested. there is a maximum amount
amount of information that you can
retain effectively. Uh there is
essentially no way around when people
just pile too much work on you. There's
essentially no way around doing work
ineffectively
and you just have to grind hours. You
can optimize other stuff with sleep and
try to like get better sleep. You know,
you can try to be fresh. You can try to
cut out other stuff, but at some point
if there's too much work, it's just
you're kind of [ __ ] High school
finishing next year.
I will say I guess I I don't know your
situation. I will say that's like the
probably the hardest and worst chunk of
my life was uh like the last year or so
of high school, year or two of high
school. Um it does get better. I don't
really have any advice for you other
than just like completely grind that so
you're good for university. I don't know
if you're in the US.
In the US it's basically just work your
ass off.
And there's no way around it.
In Europe?
In Europe, it's much easier, right? I
don't know where in Europe. Is it just
like you did your um placement to
university gets decided based on a test?
Hey, SD
Because if it is and you're already like
able to do that. Um
if if it is just on that and you are
already able to do that that gives you
more bandwidth to learn other stuff.
Yes. it determines if you're already
able to like if you're already positive
that you're going to be able to nail
that to go, you know, to the best place
that you could realistically be able to,
um, then you should end up having spare
time to learn other stuff because I can
tell you that like just knowing what
you're taught in high school, by the
time you get in college, you're at a
very very severe disadvantage because
all these opportunities open up to you,
but you are not qualified to know which
of them are actually interesting or
viable because you don't have any deep
experience in any of these fields. And
intro classes are a very very bad uh way
to judge like what types of fields uh
what fields you're interested in and
what types of problems you'd like to
work on.
Stopped using cloud code. I still use it
a little bit. I'd like to have it more
out of my workflow. Uh it's very very
stupid. It is useful in
I think it's mostly useful in situations
where you have deterministic relatively
deterministic operations like a very
well-defined refactor op or whatever.
You are stuck with a big messy codebase
that's pretty much takes forever to edit
manually and you can't do anything about
it. Uh most of the time you should like
you should work very hard to put
yourself into a position where you don't
have to rely on clawed code. like your
code should be short and succinct and
human friendly. Sometimes that's not
going to be possible because you're
working with third party crap that's
just awful, which is what I've been
doing with Torch, but I would like to
have that be less so the case because
this is frankly just not enjoyable in
any way. Uh you learn way less with like
relying heavily on the AI tools. You
will write code. Uh you will hand off
too much of your thinking to the AI
models and the people that build them
hate you. So yeah,
I will still write the blog at some
point. I've been busy like building
actual stuff though.
Do you still re review code? Uh, yes I
do still review code. I get backlogged
quite a bit. It depends how long of a
review you need though, right? Like
really big NPRs that that are going to
take me three or four hours to review, I
have to like set aside a good day to do
that.
It also has to be at least reasonable
code for that. uh for newer contributors
that write like a 4 500 line end
that I can review pretty quickly like
whenever on a stream.
I will be mad though if it's all AI
generated crap.
this is Super Maven. It's no longer
available, unfortunately. Cursor bought
it and killed it. And then all the Super
Maven users bitched so much that they
said, "Fine, we'll keep serving it to
existing users.
let's make a quick commit
before I start messing with stuff.
reads are just decreasing. I don't know
what that is. That means
Yeah. The one thing SFing you absolutely
do not want to bungle is a university or
undergrad. You do not want to bungle
admissions.
You're basically [ __ ] if you do.
what are you working on? Cleaning up
puffer lib. We have
some sweeps running.
Um, and I just wrote this.
I kind of went through and I s kind of
like saw where all of the bad code is.
We're going to go through and delete all
the stuff that's easy to delete first
and uh then we're going to start actual
refactors.
I think this is the only thing I can um
get rid of this as well.
Have you tried Zed?
Sweep AI autocomplete.
No, not really.
I wouldn't mind a local model. Honestly,
I don't want a good like I don't want a
super strong model. I just want a fast
model. Like I want something that has
100 ms completion time, ideally less.
Oh, I know what this is from. That's
fine.
Uh, we actually are no longer going to
need autotune, funny enough, because the
function of autotune is now handled by
sweeps completely,
which is pretty cool.
Like, sweeps fully does what autotune
used to do.
Couple hundred lines.
Uh, this one's harder to edit, I think.
Let's get rid of modules that are bad.
This is the easiest thing
to just delete things. We don't use log
colips and values, do we?
This entire thing is fused.
Oh, I didn't check kernels.cu as well.
Duh.
your code
like your the code is simple. This is
not simple code here. This is a mess
sfing. This is a complete disaster.
Um
if you want simple code like
here this is our snake implementation.
Like read this if you want like an
example of how to make a useful end in a
couple hundred lines of dead simple
code.
This is nice.
I got to write some just uh some C
environment stuff for a client yesterday
and it was so much nicer and easier than
this crap.
Like this is like this is basically me
making the best of uh the worst library
ever which is the torch back end.
And this is going to get a lot simpler
as well. We have first of all just like
a lot of dead code that we don't need to
deal with.
Um this log [ __ ] sum x
I think we should keep this.
We don't use this directly at the moment
but uh it is a useful test point I
think. PO fused loss we can delete
because we have the optimized one.
All this garbage just gets to be
deleted.
Let me see his teacher made putting
heart. Yeah, they do that though. SFing.
They really do that. I I was taught
Java. It literally took me years to
unlearn Java.
Like I don't know what type of adult
mind produces that crap, but
it's awful.
Uh some form of hardcoded hardcoded
opponent.
Down to what? 970 lines.
That's a whole bunch of crap deleted,
right?
Some part of me is like, hey, it's
really hard to get good perf without the
RMS norm. But I just know that we cannot
make a good kernel for this thing.
So I'd rather just like look elsewhere
in the architecture.
Mangru layer is good.
Default encoder.
We're using this at the moment.
And that's all the easy deletes I
believe out of here.
I don't know if it's easy to write a
scripted opponent. It's also like
reasonably fast. I don't think that is
actually an easy thing to do
on the paid plan. Yes, but I don't think
there is a paid plan anymore. SD I think
they just like copied all the current
paid users to legacy and kept and kept
supporting it. I don't even think I'm
getting build
Why do you need a scripted opponent?
Can't you just like run your sweep and
then at the end of each train just like
run the last model versus Maya or
whatever. Anything you either have an
API or local. You don't have to have
your own scripted model, right? You can
use somebody else's. Use that to
estimate the ELO. And then just give
that last point for the sweep. Does that
work?
I mean if you want to speed it up right
what you can also do is you can just use
your other models
right like you can just take your model
that's fast that you've evaluated
against Maya or whatever you assign it
an ELO based on your evals and then you
play against that for the evaluation.
Like there are a whole bunch of things
you can do to get out of this that don't
involve you having to figure out how to
make a good fast scripted model. Right?
We're kind of past that.
point sweep
speed things up know Spencer and I do
things manually so Jess um you have some
trained models right you can go manually
evaluate their ELO versus some bots and
then you can assign them an ELO score,
right? Okay. So, when you do a new run
and you want to assign an ELO to the bot
that you learned so that you can use
that ELO for the sweeps,
you would just after the training run,
you just like add a thing that runs some
games versus your other model of known
ELO and then you can compute ELO based
on win rate against that.
That gives you data for sweep and still
fast.
Yeah, exactly.
Pretty much just that. Uh, Spencer Lion
Hart.
Also, you can get close to um 5,000
score on 2048 in like 36 seconds. So,
that's pretty cool.
Get rid of this RMS colonel. This thing
sucks.
Yeah, this is not even correct. That's
all right.
view scan forward. We're just deleting
old kernels right now. We're doing like
the super easy dead code um
dead code
fixes.
Oh, there's still so much jank that we
need to clean up, isn't there?
This will at least have us with a
reasonable idea of how much actual code
we have.
Right.
Uh, po kernel,
So, these are just all old versions of
um old versions of kernels that we don't
need anymore.
So, we just clean up this dead code and
then we'll see how much we actually have
left.
FC Max board. Okay, this is the real
colonel.
The hell?
Oh yeah. Okay, we did some jank.
Fellow FC Max. Yep, this gets deleted.
This thing is crap.
I'll collect some values. RMS norm
scan
Oops.
closing values.
Mass norm.
I think I should clean this. These ones.
These ones will be LLM cleaned up. This
is LLM crap. The LLM will delete the
crap that's no longer used. Um, let's
just say that we have what's this?
Okay, we'll say we have an extra couple
hundred lines worth of these, right?
I want to say that this is mostly real
code.
It's like 5k lines, which is about what
I expect. It's about 5k lines worth of
stuff.
Right. I have to delete old uh old
kernels
when hi when I finish working on this
when I build it all
is very fast now though
hey liberty what are you doing Okay.
Doing pretty well.
Um I'm doing pretty well overall.
I'm working on just cleaning up puffer.
I'm exhausted. I had um I ran a 703 pace
5K just flat on the treadmill.
I did some deadlifts for the first time
in a few weeks. Couple other things. And
I'm pretty tired. So I'm just going to
go through and do the easy parts of the
clean up of Puffer today. you know,
where there's really not much
opportunity for me to screw stuff up.
Just get like a couple thousand lines of
stale code out of the repo
is get all this stuff out
and then um that gets us a good starting
point for tomorrow cuz when I'm fresh
tomorrow
uh I want to really start cleaning up
the repo.
when you're casting fireballs.
I do recommend that article for anybody
who has not seen the um
yeah, for anybody who has not seen the
fireball article.
I mean, it was kind of a meme, but it's
funny that it keeps getting more
relevant year after year.
It's on my articles tab alongside the
more serious stuff.
Okay, I think we're allowed to use
Claude to clean up Claude's own mess
here, right? So, all these shitty launch
functions, uh, these wrappers, just have
it like go through and delete the ones
that no longer exist.
And then we'll and then we'll be able to
actually spend our time thinking about
how to not have any of them at all. uh
once we have code that compiles because
we no longer have bad rappers.
Let's see what are we deleting. Log view
scan view scan for
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. That's all
fine. We get rid of this. This
cool
when you firing laser
barrel. You got some old memes there.
See, you must be late 20s or early 30s
just based on the memes.
going to start running again.
Yeah, running is good.
See, the annoying thing about all the
running, right, is like, you know, it's
good for you, but I have less energy for
my actual weight training after I run.
And yeah, it's good for you, but like
you get home, you look in the mirror,
and it's like, well, this does
absolutely nothing for me. Uh, on the
outside, I the cardio is good, but it's
like,
yeah, I'd be looking way better and I'd
be stronger and I'd probably feel better
overall that with that if I just spent
more of my effort lifting,
but you need the cardio regardless.
I was pretty happy with the uh the 20
minute three mile on my birthday.
That was a hell of a lot of effort.
said that counts. Yeah, but the thing is
that won't actually get you to do your
exercise and be excited to go to the
gym.
Like I go for a very hard run, I'll just
feel like awful afterwards.
and go lift some heavy stuff. And I feel
pretty good.
Really like to lift heavy rock.
There we go.
Ding ding ding. Don't worry about the
speed. We're running other stuff in the
background. That's why this is slow.
It's splitting compute. All right. Are
we ready for the um the PR that like
removes all the dead code?
This is u I mean this is the easy part
of optimization
but it's still going to be very
satisfying to see this.
So, we're going to have to work more for
our uh our lines deleted after this
So, that is about a third of the code in
the library.
Uh about a third of the code for 40 we
just deleted
because it was just old dev crap.
That's about most of this is roughly
real code.
Let me use the restroom real quick and
we will think about what I can actually
optimize today with remaining brain
cells.
right.
So,
let's see. Um, I guess the way I want to
do this is I want to kind of look at how
much code everything is and think how
much code I think there should be.
No to slop.
Brockman was always one of the guys I
respected the most. Um,
some of his latest AI stuff has been
like questionable.
Like for instance, writing [ __ ] in Rust
because it's easier for AI to get it
right is awful cuz Rust is just an
absolutely [ __ ] language for people.
1100 lines of pop followed by lines of
modules and 1,000 lines of models.
Okay.
Main refactor questions
mean a hell of a lot of the code is just
bloat from um BF16 First 32 to be fair.
Let me see how we're doing it now.
Actually,
let me Yeah, let me see how we're doing
it now.
So just conditioned on DT type
launch mining gate.
This is not a kernel launch though. This
is a wrapper function.
I want to see if I can reduce.
We've got very stupid branching at the
moment.
This is something I don't fully
understand though because this is C++
garbage.
The torch code would be way better if I
didn't have the branching.
Oh, we are using VF. Wait, no, we're
not.
It's stupid, right?
Mini gate in French colonel.
All the other launch functions still use
at.
Why do we need it this way?
Launch.
I have it right here. Right. It's like
oft
Why does Torch have their own stupid be
love?
I'm thinking you just call the colonel.
No.
Let me just try something real quick.
Let's just see if Claude's stupid
because it very well could just be
stupid.
It's worth binging with this to figure
this out.
Um, it can't possibly be this hard to be
handling multiple D types, right?
I just love when we get no [ __ ] error
message on import. That's just amazing,
man.
Terrible language.
Absolutely terrible language.
I don't understand how this builds,
but this doesn't import
being an idiot. Yes, you're just being
an idiot, dude.
Maybe. Just don't be an idiot.
Okay,
hang on. This could still be viable.
I could also think if there's a non-
template way to do this.
kind of a funny problem to be having.
Now,
let me go think about this a little bit.
I'm going to go get a refresh on my tea
as well.
I got an idea, Jeff.
I got an idea on how to do this.
You think we could leverage proper to
get better weather models?
I think Bruno, we're getting five inches
of snow.
Doesn't deep mind do that?
I don't see how it's an RL problem.
Let me try this myself.
So what we do is
like this. Right.
Launch main gate inference.
Remove this
void.
need to cast inside the lost launch
function.
Okay.
Wait, that's a weird That is a weird
conversion, isn't it?
That's a weird cast.
I mean, the thing is this is all just
like C++ being troll and [ __ ]
There's really no reason to have this.
This also shouldn't need a cast,
should I? No, wait. It should
too many arguments.
HB stream D type
void void convoid convoid int stream
probably missing it in the H
int
type
Let's just see if this works at all.
Oops.
Why does this not work?
Can we not copy? We can copy
I want to have something that works
though first so we can like compare it
to um
Templates are compile level, right? Like
it gets compiled the same as if I wrote
it out explicitly. So it is fast like
this is not overhead right I guess there
is the from float function call but if
we inline it it should be fine right
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
expected scalar
doesn't show the module one bit. It's
very weird.
Sub 5 second. Thank you.
I don't know. It sound It seemed like a
good thing to post in a reply.
for lib.
Come on
in gate. Yeah.
How about this?
Yeah.
tensor B
tensor base.
Just use data pointer with no template.
Gotcha.
If it doesn't exist, then why does this
build? Huh? C++. Have you thought about
that?
I'm basically I'm just trying to figure
out how we can simplify all this
template crap.
You have to do a
It's so gross.
This is annoying.
Very very annoying.
So, I mean, we're stuck then, right?
It's either macro or to or conditional,
right?
At least it wouldn't be in the torch
code, right?
And then it's just this.
Oh, that's so much nicer, man.
Look at this little tiny thing by
comparison.
not to be pushed if it works. Very nice.
Very nice.
This thing works too, doesn't it?
That actually if we can get that that
would at least be um
I do think it's worth spending time on
this because um I'm going to say like a
good quarter to third of the jank at the
moment comes from our DT type handling.
Let me look at let me just stare at this
for a few moments guys. Does anybody
have any ideas?
I mean we have this down now. So
we need one macro globally,
very light templating and like these
cast functions.
state the problem. So I am essentially
trying to uh simplify the way that we
handle multiple dtypes in our kernels,
right? Because we need to support float
32. Uh we need to support BF16.
Ideally, it would be very nice if we
could support more DTypes than that
without having to add explicit
branching. Uh the problem is that I can
only see two methods of doing this that
are not explicit branching. One is that
you have a macro. So you essentially you
write your explicit branching once and
then the macro applies it. I don't like
this because it tends to produce really
jank compile errors, but at least it's
short and it's C native. Uh the other
thing is templating the kernels
themselves. Uh I have this here so that
you can pl you can pass in floatar or
bflatar to this. And
I don't know if there's another way
around this. Essentially,
I guess we could try to do what
templates do with a macro.
I think that the from float and to float
can be
macro, right?
Yeah. You end up writing your whole code
in macros.
check on our um
our experiments.
Oh, we have some runs here. Look at
this.
They're not great, but we have them.
This is where I think that the um uh the
model is actually useful here. Like I
just spent a while going through this
thinking about this and now this
operation of applying this to all the
kernels is uh this is like a
deterministic op right this is a pure
refactor op you know exactly the outcome
workflow the best cla workflow is going
to be when claud is out of my workflow
frankly
I mean, this templating op is such a
weird thing to have to do as well. It's
like so uncommon that you get something
that looks like this.
Clippy.
This is Clippy up here except the puffer
version.
Hey Peru.
Oh, perfect timing. Actually,
do you have any better way of doing um
the Bflat and float handling than this?
I spent a little bit of time on this and
this is the best thing that I could come
up with. So, we keep the uh the
inference, we keep these kernels pretty
much exactly the way that they are now.
Um we
uh we put one macro in the launch
function here for the dispatch and then
the torch just calls this. So the torch
doesn't have any macro or templating at
all and it's just passive as void are
mini grew.
Yeah. So the problem is
well if I do that right then I need to
write there has to be an if statement
for every single kernel conditioned on
the dtype and then even if I do that
like I still don't get to delete the
templating from the kernels themselves
right so I'm stuck with it anyways if
there were a way to do all of this
without templating thing, I'd be very
very happy. But other than literally
copy pasting the entire kernel twice, I
don't and then putting a conditional. I
don't think there is
Also, I think we have some speed issues
with my version of the vectorzation. I
think you're right when you said like
that there are um some issues
provide type of compilation. That's
assembly essentially what the templates
do. Yeah. So, I like the thing is I
think you end up needing both because
the problem with mac uh the problem with
templates is that they're kind of
cancer, right? Like you end up having to
propagate the templates all the way up
through your code.
Holy crap. All right, let's see. What do
we have here?
Well, we get rid of all the nice all
these bad rappers. So that's already a
bunch of code deleted.
I pretty much I went through one of
these carefully and now I'm just having
it like
apply the exact same change to all the
kernels cuz it's like a really dumb
simple deterministic op, right?
I guess the uh the alternative to the
templates would be if we just only if we
just decided screw it, we're supporting
one DT type, right?
That's weird.
I think we need more profiles on the
ends.
I I guess technically we could just
decide that all the kernels are Bflat
or we could just decide that like every
kernel is just one DT type.
No, we wouldn't do purely float 32
though. If anything, it would be purely
Bflat 16.
a 2B float one time. It's not a one time
cost. Then if you do it that way, so you
like if you pass,
you essentially end up doing the exact
same thing. That cast is a kernel call.
So you end up wasting all that memory
bandwidth.
Um,
there is stuff with FP8 we could look
into.
I the numeric are so sketchy with that.
No clean solutions other than the
templates. I guess what we'll do is
we'll revisit this after we've used
Puffer 4 for a while, right? You know,
because we can run some experiments.
Hey, do we ever need FP32, right? like
is that ever a stability concern when
you have nice fused kernels like this?
And if the answer is no, maybe we just
decide, you know what, we're just doing
B float 16 for everything
Okay. They're um
Claude. Let's see what we have. This
looks big and scary, but this should be
this should be basically free. This is
an incredibly well- definfined
operation.
This is just replacing casts with the um
equivalents.
likes to delete literally all of my
comments.
Back to topic.
Cheaper compute much slower than 3.0
bottl non590s.
So similar to multiprock. Yeah. So I
Peru I noticed this as well. I don't
understand what's going on. Uh I think I
have a dated speed test. Like there's n
speedc
and then there's like a newer one that
has other outdated tests around it and
profile kernels. I think we need to
pretty heavily profile everything and
figure out what the heck is going on.
Cuz it should be very fast.
You said that you got a version of it
that works without using OM as well.
Like we can try that. I think I like the
most helpful thing if you want to get
involved with this um of course we need
a version of this that actually lets you
test stably.
But uh the main thing would just be like
you know little benchmark try the ends
see what the heck is going on. It should
scale as expected. If it doesn't we need
to know why.
If you have improvements you know test
before test after that sort of thing.
cuz there's definitely a VE bottleneck
and there absolutely shouldn't be with
the current design.
go was a bit different to balance
based non-MP. Well, I definitely want
the multi-thread optimizations. Peru
and I think that there's going to be a
spot in the future where we're going to
want to drop torch entirely and a lot of
the ways that you've come up to do thing
come up with for doing things are going
to be very applicable.
I mean, even the LSTM, I suppose, would
be good. Like, we could we might even
want to just use the LSTM as a back end
because we can't use BF-16 with Nvidia
as nicely. Like, they don't have a good
um BF-16 back end from what I can tell.
Okay, do this.
Uhoh. Minus 400 lines of code.
Presumably, it forgot to modify modules,
right?
Yep.
Oh, I'm being signaled for dinner. Um,
I'm going to go get dinner. You got an
insane break up. 5 second. Yes. Using
sweep. It's sweeps Peru. Um, I think we
can go faster. I got to get dinner. So,
I might stream a little later. I don't
know. I'm definitely live all day
tomorrow though. And I think the main
thing is just going to be cleaning up
Puffer nicely for the release. So, if
that's interesting you, you can watch
tomorrow, anybody. And um we are really
really close to 5,000 stars flat. This
is rounding up. It's like 25 to go or
something. So, please star the puffer on
GitHub. It's free. It helps me out.
Follow on X if you want more RL content
and join Discord to get involved. Thank
you all.